[Music]
oh yes the men in Blazers who promised
to appear on this show with a tweet
yesterday attached of me on SportsCenter
I think back in 1999
when I was hoping to be the the host of
the two-minute drill well this is the N
at the time Michael Davis that is when I
first met you and you always picture
people the way they look when you first
need them we asked your people through
an up-to-date headshot that's what they
you look younger now to me then you do
this that say on our show the baldness
is truth Rich Eisen
yes and I say we also say something else
on our show that's not sure if I'm
allowed to say on your Roger Bennett you
may say whatever you wish you are a bill
you are a bill 3 is'nt bill I'm trying
to figure out yeah I think I understand
what you are a role model for today's
bold American that's all I will tell you
I really initiate that right and there's
a clapping from another fine bull aboard
we all follow your lead now as a nation
writer follow Ritchie sizing wherever he
tells you to get Brotherhood so I guess
this would be great way to start Roger
Bennett Michael Davies the men in
Blazers beyond their Blazers here in
person yeah along with the men in
Blazers present encyclopedia blazer
Tanika yeah a sub-optimal guide to
soccer American sport for the future
since 1970 sport of the future since
1972 we're now where does 72 what where
does that come in oh it's just one of
the first podcast we ever did
we were both joined by a love for two
things we love America there's not a day
I do not wake up and thank God that live
in this country in fact this time next
week this very town I'm going to be
sworn in as an American citizen which
may be the the singular great
achievement of my life and the other
thing I love obviously soccer football
and when we both came here in the early
90s football was always the sport of the
future sport of the 80s was always like
a Rubik's Cube of a fad but while we've
been here we have witnessed and rather
than overnight success a slow and steady
climb driven by a variety of different
factors the rise
the internet which allows you to connect
a United Chelsea city as closely as if
you live in the same zip code EA SPORTS
FIFA just a MBC's job of broadcasting
the Premier Li World Cups all those
things footballs isn't as slowly become
an incredibly American sport for anyone
noticing and it's one of the stories
which we we try and mark down in this
point and yet the greatest thing is it's
still the sport of the future because
every day somebody else will come up to
me and say when do you think soccer is
gonna make it in this country it's
always it's always it's always down the
road well I've lost track of the number
of of times that Team USA has scored a
big goal and that was the moment that
Landon Donovan planted a flag for the
sport here in this country we were just
filling the black madly it could change
from 1950 England the gray England team
lost to the USA who played a
minor-league washed-up baseball player
in goal they had a Haitian drycleaner at
Stryker yeah the u.s. won 1 nil the
manager of the team was the first person
to wear that doom phrase this is all we
need to make the sport go in America no
one cared at USA didn't qualify for
another 40 years but you do you have
Landon Donovan at the last World Cup
yeah John Brooks screwing it to ghanians
in the last second falling to his knees
and crying incredible memories you will
not have these at the next World Cup
2018 breaking news the u.s. did not
qualify but say they'll have an amazing
World Cup and Americans will love it is
that right yeah cuz you love a circus
you love an excuse to date I'm Dre time
drinking time drinking yeah who's gonna
be filming your show for 31 days well
the world comes on because these they're
all gonna be watching and Americans will
follow that narrative which we try and
Mark out in this book even without an
American kicking a football in it yeah
so why hasn't this for Americans like
sports that they can win Americans are
winners yes I mean it's amazing when you
come and you watch the Olympics yes um
it's annoying watching the Olympics if
you're if you're a non-american when
you're outside the country when you come
to America and it's
literally a parade of Americans winning
things you understand that they're
playing to the audience because
Americans like winning and winning and
winning promise even if you're the
greatest soccer nation in the world you
you lose quite a lot like soccer is
about loss it's as much about loss as it
is about winning I'm not sure that
American sports fans the sort of the
sort of average American sports fan is
really down the dream-team the first
time I saw them and watch Charles
Barkley elbow a hapless Angolan in the
head I was with Americans watching that
game and their words were not what you
like to win dominant I said why would
you do that to that pouring of the like
shut up it's the way you also love the
Miracle on Ice you know the winning
underdog don't like is an America that
sometimes wins sometimes doesn't it
early or not in this World Cup Chilean
on this World Cup the Netherlands a
great day or not there would be people
there'll be 50 percent unbelievable neck
tattoo 50 cent unless unbelievable neck
tattoos because Chile or not at this
Yale Cup but those nations will be fine
they're still embraced the telenovela
kind of narrative there is a World Cup
and I'll tell you the big shock of this
World Cup is that America will - even
without an American kicking a football
with joy or in anger the thing is rich
yes my World Cup is not really about
soccer
what is it about it's about the
narrative the continuing narrative of
these players who are like soap opera
figures and allies it's taking place in
Russia I mean what a setting for like
season 15 of the World Cup it's just
it's a great setting it's sort of like
Survivor where they come up with a new
plot twist this year put it in Russia
like have all of that political and sort
of geopolitical intrigue it's gonna be
about crowd violence it's gonna be about
cossacks on horseback we've we're
controlling with whips controlling the
islands what could probably go wrong
it's gonna be these great players neck
tattoos simulation all the things that
Americans hate about the sport there are
actually the things that when you view
it as not a sport but a spectacle to
watch while you're daytime drinking it
just is what makes it excellent about
Ronaldo and Messi the two guys battling
for goat status one of them a preening
show pony who like almost doesn't like
football buddy
loves love's love so much taking his top
off shirt off he couldn't care less
about the football yeah if I score a
goal I get to get my nipples out almost
anybody in the world again and again and
again he's done it decade over a decade
just like superlative football Drakon
wore wafting off Roger Bennett Michael
Davies men in Blazers here
have we confirmed yeah that Ronaldo yeah
does in fact use Drakkar Noir I tell a
story you are calm attract are we argued
river editor it's in the noir slash
comma Drecker I was in which is a
beautiful city if you have the chance to
go to Ukraine my people were chased out
of it for generations behind every door
in my life to this day I'm full of fear
of them but they sent me to Don edge and
I checked into a hotel just after
Portugal had been knocked out the World
Cup and lo and behold I was in Renaldo's
room and I write in the book how like
months later my luggage still stank of
dreck on watch just by osmosis for
having checked into the same the same
rather beautiful rumors that I can by
experience still some days when the wind
hits me in the right direction a surplus
track I remember once one of the first
basketball games I ever watch was was
watching who was the guy used to do the
MBA the the the amazing guy who was
Marisa yeah am a Jewish address we're
sitting by yeah I'm learn to speak Roger
was being interviewed and the interview
just stopped in the middle and goes oh
my god amad you're wearing enough
aftershave for the both of us that's how
it is when you [ __ ] when you sleep in
Renaldo's the bedrooms we're breaking
we're breaking these and show fan base
the only equivalent for me is when I I
covered the Hall of Fame for the NFL
Network and we were using across the
street from the steps of Canton Ohio we
were using the
Sports Hollywood hotel which was this
which was this this box that was
hermetically sealed that they used for
NASCAR so you could not hear the roar of
the engines will be able to speak mom
yes so we were using that because right
across the street from the Hall of
famous i-77 in Ohio so that we wanted to
drown out the noise there and inside the
Hollywood hotel was Chris Myers of Fox
Sports his big tall Paul Mitchell can of
hairspray uh-huh that's the only
equivalent I have right there in my
career where's Michael I guess you're
the arbiter here which which one's a
better brush with Fame well I mean you
asked rod for what the fact was I mean I
the connection of ROG and facts is like
it's pretty it's pretty loose of course
all true of course Christiana does not
let Drakkar Noir he wears Cristiano it
may be it may smell a lot like Drakkar
Noir
it may be modeled after Drakkar Noir but
it is not actual track on the wall I
want to take a 60-second break we're
back with more with Roger Bennett and
Michael Davies they want to talk about
your tour you're going around the
country you're here in Los Angeles
performing here with very I want to find
out what the are we seeing the
performance essentially right now
partnership with Embassy Row that I
wanted as well crackle I want to make
sure I want to make sure everybody's
everything I'm gonna hit that's what I
do I touch all the bases list okay we're
back in 60 seconds with the men in
Blazers Roger Bennett Michael David
[Music]
all right lots to get to in this segment
with Roger Bennett Michael Davies the
men in Blazers you can catch their show
and it comes back from hiatus on NBCSN
of course the book that's in Roger
Bennett's hand right now the
Encyclopedia Blazer Tanika is available
what all book stores of both observes
bought yeah but before we get into all
this here
we like to be fact-based here on the
rich I know Chris Brockman you have the
actual nut of the actual issue with
details on Ron Ronaldo's sent oh yeah
okay so that the official title is cr7
yeah yeah and you can get a two piece
gift set mm-hmm
that includes you know the cologne spray
1.7 ounces of spray yeah and then a 5
ounce shower gel that's very good now
here's the description on on these
products here they dress horn wah ripoff
is it what it says not quite sporty
energetic and modern cr7 is a fragrance
for the spontaneous on-the-go young man
yeah an intoxicating blend of classic
foo gray notes and addictive woods and
spices Mike you made me watch drinking
seven volt notes fo you GE re oh god I
don't know cr7 is a contemporary
cocktail of bold daring sense reflective
of Ronaldo strong vibrant care ho oh
what dim the lights what they come out
and spray on somebody who goes down
because he's been touched by a cuticle
and then they spray it and then all of a
sudden he comes back from off the
stretcher and runs like a gazelle spray
it's also the spray that they spray to
do the ten yards listening to this
beautiful description I've realized the
answer to rid this question about when
football is made it's soccers made in
this country yes is when the children of
America are walking around wearing
Landon Donovan aftershave
America live in that America David
that's when we know that maybe well you
that's why you're trying that's where
you're gonna be a citizen you're gonna
be a full-fledged member yeah LD 10 what
is this tour about you're here in Los
Angeles and then middle of June st.
Louis Seattle Portland San Francisco
before hitting the East Coast what do
you have what are you guys doing the
world cup is a remarkable time and it
for us it gives us the spine of our
memories whenever you name a year I
immediately default to the nearest world
cup and can remember Slumdog Millionaire
style just like the incredible
collective memories mostly of English do
and participation America are not in
this world cup and it's you know the
London Donovan memory against Algeria
that you talked about where thousands of
bars are uptil din just incredible joy
around soccer that's not gonna there
won't be new American memories this the
World Cup there will be next year when
the US women win the World Cup but what
we wanted to do was to tour the country
bring Americans together around the
delirious can a narrative of the World
Cup city to city starting in the great
city of st. Louis moving down the west
coast the East Coast and really just
revel together in what we were about to
see which is you know the World Cup it's
there's Simon Cooper the great soccer
writer once said when two teams in the
World Cup take the field their nation's
history take the field alongside of them
so there's some of that and then there's
just human drama it's humanity we're
gonna have we're gonna watch shared
humanity heroes villains joy failure do
national glory and furl and we wanted to
bring Americans together city-by-city
night by night and really just revel in
every set yeah that's what we're gonna
be watching the games during the day as
we're traveling between the cities
walking they time there may be some
daytime drinking rich yeah and then
we're going to talk about the games at
night and it is a it's an American tour
one of the problems that we've
discovered about American I've been here
for 28 years I should really know better
yes it's a really big country there are
a lot of cities which means say you're
going on American tour it's pretty much
impossible to go to to even scratch the
surface of all the cities you've got
Brooklyn Philly Boston Atlanta and DC
and your crackle partnership with
Embassy Row Circle Sony crackle Florida
Sony crackles
Embassy Row is
an organization with which I am
personally familiar yes having been
friends and worked with you in various
ways last couple of decades
hospice osha through embassy row if I'm
not mistaken yeah created good morning
football morning look a major hit right
and then I found that work those guys so
what do you do it like finish this
sentence well no so Embassy Row is the
production company that's my day job
the of richest I probably should not
mention daytime drinking around my day
job but Embassy Row running Embassy Row
the production company is my day job
Emma sphere also produces many places
produces lots of other shows and sports
and entertainment the great Andy Cohen
show I know Andy then great guy
so we're doing we a few years ago make
previews for the World Cup when we were
working with Grant land with with Bill
Simmons over there we've made previews
again for this World Cup they're
available on Sony crackle so go and
check those out they're gonna be coming
out just a few days time okay fantastic
so you got that going on yep we got the
tool we got the book TV show we'll be
back
Liverpool and really gain this we want
to break that down for me yeah I think
I'm some serious football okay here's
the thing two teams who are amazing on
the counter-attack Liverpool the third
player we should really talk about in
the world who really emerged this year
Mohamed Salah have Liverpool a fantastic
Egyptian player a player who's literally
United the Middle East whether you're
whatever whatever flavor of Muslim
you're Shia Sunni whichever country
you're from you see the most salad
jersey all the way around the Arab world
he is beloved by by Muslims beloved by
Christians beloved by sort of everybody
the most likable lovely fast tiny little
football he plays with such joy he's
gonna be playing for Liverpool against
cristiano of Real Madrid two teams so
powerful on the counter-attack it's I
think gonna be a cagey affair mmm-hmm we
know how Americans love a low-scoring
soccer game I don't think it's gonna be
a shootout and he's gonna be a cagey
affair whoever scores first wins that's
my prediction Roger I think it's gonna
be anything it'd be like American League
baseball and it's d-h and kind of peak
is well it's just things you talking are
like it
what is it BH I'm a huge White Sox fan
chess with chewing tobacco baseball we
absolutely adore you it will be a
high-scoring affair she was loved to
attack neither can really defend with
any true confidence it's gonna be a
psychological battle Liverpool not
unlike the the the Vegas Golden Knights
no one expected them to be in the final
yeah there they play this Buccaneer and
the football I'm from the city of
Liverpool there's two teams Liverpool
like the Yankees Everton the Mets and
fortune I'm a never tonin but even I
can't begrudge their success run by this
German who's like a Teutonic Jim harbour
guy could Jurgen Klopp an incredible
motivational German yeah and it will be
a joy to watch this game tomorrow too if
they if they succeed they are if you
like happiness if you like joy if you
like human wonder watch this team and
this little mouse our who's I could tiny
little Ewok tiny little hair bear he
also has the the assassination abilities
of like a West world host they're
infused in one little human being watch
him
savor love it American we should just
you shouldn't even have to take the test
to become an American with all those pop
culture references you just made to try
and to try and draw understandable
references to the American but the truth
is this is that this is honestly whist
both massive American sports fans yes
we've been here a long time when we came
here the internet didn't exist soccer
didn't exist
I mean don't even start me on the 1989
1990 Orlando Magic starting lineup I
could go on for ages about I was like I
lived every single game of that season
and you grew up in Liverpool in the
1980s you watch The Love Boat you watch
heart-to-heart you watch Fantasy Island
then you say life can be lived in color
I want to go there because we want to
leave you in a better way than we found
you we were gonna play start bench cut
but Chris do you wanna
you pulled up some some I have a
practice test for your citizenship would
you like to
okay yeah I hope the eye on this insr
watching you nervous again when must all
men register for the selective service
I'm ready to fight now is that the right
answer the correct answer it's [ __ ] 18
I'm not even becoming a citizen I know
the answer to that yeah next question in
what month do we vote for president
November November correct the Federalist
Papers supported the passage of the US
Constitution named one of the writers
James Madison
correct well you've seen Hamilton right
my degrees in America the House of
Representatives has how many voting
members that's good no enough 435 that's
basically correct who is the governor of
your state right now we hope you are
still around so you can go to st. Louis
on June 14th to kick off your think
about the Rockford Files yeah what was
the name of his best friend I can't
remember
angel I'm ago angel the dog haha all I
know is mrs. Hart my name's max cause
when they met it was muy muy de America
I loved watching you guys and I can't
wait to read your encyclopedia blazer
Tanika Roger Bennett at embassy Davey's
on Twitter for each at men and blazers
as well go check out encyclopedia
encyclopedia and blazer Tanika and I
hate everything that we do
come back anytime gentlemen you got it
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience